Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you to take a moment to fill out our listener survey. We want to learn more about you and about what you think of the podcast. So if you would, please go to our website, www.Speakingsophysiology.org and look for the link to our listener survey. We'd really appreciate it. Now, on to the episode. Ageism. It's one prejudice that many of us share, and many of us may face it if we're lucky enough to live a long life.
在今天开始之前，我想请大家花点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们想更多地了解你们，以及你们对本播客的看法。如果可以的话，请访问我们的网站 www.Speakingsophysiology.org，找到听众调查问卷的链接。我们将不胜感激。现在，进入本期节目。年龄歧视。这是我们许多人共同持有的一种偏见，如果我们有幸长寿，我们许多人可能都会面临这种偏见。
From cosmetics ads that promise a fountain of youth to those ubiquitous OK boomer memes, it's pretty clear that in American culture, old is synonymous with pasture prime and aging is seen as something to dread. But psychologists research suggests that contrary to the myths and stereotypes we may have absorbed, aging often comes with positive changes. And by believing in and propagating negative myths about aging, we can do ourselves. real harm. So what do the physical, cognitive, and emotional changes that come with age actually look like? What do we lose and what do we gain as we age? How much of our aging is under our control and how much is determined by genetics or luck? How does the age bias and discrimination
从承诺青春永驻的化妆品广告，到随处可见的“OK boomer”（好吧，婴儿潮一代）表情包，很明显，在美国文化中，“老”是“过气”的代名词，而衰老被视为一件令人恐惧的事情。但心理学研究表明，与我们可能吸收的那些神话和刻板印象相反，衰老往往伴随着积极的变化。通过相信和传播关于衰老的负面神话，我们实际上是在伤害自己。那么，随着年龄增长而产生的生理、认知和情感变化到底是什么样的呢？我们在变老的过程中失去了什么，又得到了什么？我们的衰老有多少是在我们的控制之下，又有多少是由基因或运气决定的？年龄偏见和歧视是如何
that people experience in their daily lives affect them and what kinds of interventions are researchers developing that could help us all stay happy and healthy in older adulthood? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Manfred Deal, a university distinguished professor in the Department of Human and Family Studies at Colorado State University. He has a lifespan developmental psychologist who studies adult development with a focus on how to achieve successful and healthy aging.
人们在日常生活中所经历的这些偏见和歧视是如何影响他们的？研究人员正在开发什么样的干预措施，以帮助我们所有人保持快乐和健康地步入老年？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是科罗拉多州立大学人类与家庭研究系杰出大学教授曼弗雷德·迪尔（Manfred Diehl）博士。他是一位研究成人发展的寿命发展心理学家，专注于如何实现成功和健康的衰老。
He studies how middle-aged and older adults become aware of their own aging and how self-perceptions of aging are related to people's physical health and psychological well-being. He has won many awards for his research and mentoring and is co-author of the book, The Psychology of Later Life, a contextual perspective published by APA. Dr. Deal, thank you for joining me today. Well, it's a pleasure to be here. I mentioned in the introduction that many of us have internalized a lot of myths about aging, So I want to start by exploring and I hope dispelling some of those myths.
他研究中年和老年人如何意识到自己的衰老，以及对衰老的自我认知如何与人们的身体健康和心理幸福感相关联。他因其研究和指导工作获得了许多奖项，并且是美国心理学会（APA）出版的《晚年心理学：背景视角》（The Psychology of Later Life, a contextual perspective）一书的合著者。迪尔博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。很高兴来到这里。我在介绍中提到，我们许多人已经内化了许多关于衰老的误区，所以我想先探讨并希望能消除其中一些误区。
You've written that one of the biggest misconceptions that the growing older primarily involves loss and decline. Can you talk about that? What does the research actually say? Indeed, one of the big myths is that aging is only loss and decline. But I think we have, of course, now research from the number of decades where we have seen that it is really, the picture is more complex. Although there are areas where decline occurs, especially if people do not use the specific functions, like for example, there is
您曾写道，最大的误解之一是认为变老主要意味着损失和衰退。您能谈谈这一点吗？研究到底是怎么说的？确实，最大的误区之一就是认为衰老只有损失和衰退。但我认为，我们当然已经有了几十年的研究，我们看到情况实际上更为复杂。虽然在某些领域确实会出现衰退，特别是如果人们不使用特定的功能，例如，
normal age-related loss in people in terms of muscle strength or bone loss if people don't exercise, right? There are normal age-related changes in our sensory systems, such as vision and hearing. But on the other hand, there are also area where there are quite some gains where people become, for example, happier. Social relationships tend to increase personality. It tends to improve that people become more agreeable and conscientious over time. And so it's, we really need to look at what are the areas where there are challenges that can be addressed to some extent. And where do people really have vast opportunities to actually get better over time? So there is a common notion that mental decline starts as
如果人们不锻炼，在肌肉力量或骨质流失方面会出现正常的与年龄相关的损失，对吧？我们的感官系统，如视觉和听觉，也会出现正常的与年龄相关的变化。但另一方面，也有一些领域会有相当大的收获，例如人们变得更快乐。社会关系往往会增加，人格往往会改善，人们随着时间的推移变得更随和、更尽责。因此，我们确实需要看看哪些领域存在可以一定程度上解决的挑战，以及人们在哪些方面确实拥有随着时间推移而变得更好的巨大机会。所以，有一种普遍的观点认为，智力衰退早在
early as people's 30s. How did this notion arise and what's wrong with it? Yeah. We're Well, yeah, this notion is unfortunately still around and based on longitudinal data, for example, especially data from the Seattle Longitudinal Study, we know by now that in relatively healthy adults, normative age-related decline in most cognitive functions does not occur before the age of 60. Now, when I say that, there are some exceptions. We, for example, know that, again, in most people, age-related decline in some cognitive functions, such as speed of information processing, may occur earlier, especially if people don't use those functions, right?
人们30多岁时就开始了。这种观点是如何产生的？它有什么问题？嗯，这种观点不幸地仍然存在。根据纵向数据，例如特别是来自西雅图纵向研究的数据，我们现在知道，在相对健康的成年人中，大多数认知功能中正常的与年龄相关的衰退在60岁之前并不会发生。现在，当我这么说时，有一些例外。例如，我们知道，同样，在大多数人中，一些认知功能（如信息处理速度）与年龄相关的衰退可能会更早发生，特别是如果人们不使用这些功能的话，对吧？
But overall, this dismiss about that age-related decline in cognitive ability starts as early as, let's say, mid or late 20s or early 30s really came out of a misinterpretation of findings because so many early studies were done just as cross-sectional studies comparing people of different ages against each other and what those kind of research designs do they actually confound age with cohort. For example, in those studies, people who are in their 60s or 70s very often perform lower because maybe they didn't have the same level of education, right? Or again, disuse has already occurred, which really, you know, we cannot then draw clear conclusions what is due to just aging and what is due to other factors, including the effect of, for example,
但总的来说，关于认知能力与年龄相关的衰退早在20多岁中后期或30多岁初期就开始的这种说法，实际上源于对研究结果的误解，因为许多早期研究只是横断面研究，比较了不同年龄段的人，而这种研究设计实际上混淆了年龄和世代。例如，在这些研究中，60多岁或70多岁的人表现往往较低，因为他们可能没有接受过同等水平的教育，对吧？或者，正如我所说，废用已经发生，这使得我们无法得出明确的结论，即哪些是由于单纯的衰老，哪些是由于其他因素，包括例如
when a person was born. Now, another one of the misconceptions that you have been working to dispel is that the changes that happen with aging are beyond people's control. Now, I understand you have shown that that's not necessarily the case. Well, not necessarily I have shown it, but when I wrote about it, I drew on literature that clearly indicates that, for example, the portion of genetic variance that affects aging is much smaller as estimated by behavioral geneticists than what we can do through our lifestyle. And of course, the important aspect of lifestyle factors. And when I refer to lifestyle factors, I mean what we eat, how physically active we are, how we manage stress, whether we smoke or don't smoke, whether we maintain a normal body weight. Lifestyle factors are really under our control.
一个人出生时间的影响。现在，您一直致力于消除的另一个误解是，衰老过程中发生的变化超出了人们的控制范围。据我了解，您已经证明情况并非一定如此。嗯，不一定是我证明了这一点，但在我撰写相关内容时，我参考了文献，这些文献清楚地表明，例如，行为遗传学家估计，影响衰老的遗传变异比例远小于我们可以通过生活方式改变的部分。当然，生活方式因素是一个重要方面。当我提到生活方式因素时，我指的是我们的饮食、身体活动的程度、我们如何管理压力、是否吸烟、是否保持正常的体重。生活方式因素确实在我们的控制之下。
And therefore, the influence that we can have through our own behavior, and behavior here also includes our attitude towards growing older. It's, of course, much larger than most people know. How do people's personalities change as they age? I'm just wondering what happens with respect to the Big Five personality traits over time. Actually, the news in the personality area is quite positive. We know, for example, one of the major things. traits in the Big Five nomenclature is neuroticism or emotional instability. We know that people
因此，我们可以通过自身行为产生的影响，这里的行为也包括我们对变老的态度，当然要比大多数人知道的大得多。人们的性格随着年龄的增长会发生怎样的变化？我很好奇“大五人格”特质随着时间的推移会发生什么变化。事实上，人格领域的消息相当积极。例如，我们知道“大五人格”命名法中的主要特质之一是神经质或情绪不稳定性。我们知道人们
over time tend to go down in neuroticism. That means people become emotionally on average, more stable. We know that conscientiousness tends to increase at least until the mid-60s, possibly early 70s in those studies where we have data on the age group. We also know that agreeableness, that means how well we get along with others, whether our tendency to be cantankerous, we're mellowing out perhaps a little bit more. So in the overall, the conclusion from several meta-analysis is in the personality area, we see quite a bit of positive development in terms of becoming socially more mature. Coping strategies tend to improve, and emotion regulation also tends to improve,
随着时间的推移，神经质往往会下降。这意味着人们平均而言在情绪上变得更加稳定。我们知道，尽责性往往会增加，至少在60多岁中期之前，甚至在70多岁初期（在那些我们有该年龄组数据的研究中）。我们还知道宜人性，即我们与他人相处得如何，我们是否倾向于变得暴躁，也许我们变得更加温和了。因此，总的来说，几项荟萃分析得出的结论是，在人格领域，我们在变得社会化更成熟方面看到了相当多的积极发展。应对策略往往会改善，情绪调节也往往会改善，
which is, of course, very important for both individual well-being, but also for getting along with others. And so is this directly related to the fact that the prevalence of major psychiatric disorders is lower in people over 60 compared with younger people? Yes, with some caveat, I want to point out. You know, another misconception is, of course, that all old people are depressed, lonely and sad and so on. And real data actually does not support that. For example, in all major epidemiological studies, older adults tend to show higher life satisfaction and subjective well-being than younger age groups. But moreover, those studies that have looked at the major psychiatric disorders and their distribution in different age groups have shown that the prevalence rate of all major psychiatric disorders, and their distribution in different age groups have shown that the prevalence rate of all major psychiatric disorders,
这当然对个人幸福感和与他人相处都非常重要。那么，这是否与60岁以上人群中主要精神疾病的患病率低于年轻人这一事实直接相关？是的，但我想指出一些注意事项。你知道，另一个误区当然是认为所有老年人都抑郁、孤独和悲伤等等。而真实数据实际上并不支持这一点。例如，在所有主要的流行病学研究中，老年人往往表现出比年轻年龄组更高的生活满意度和主观幸福感。而且，那些研究了主要精神疾病及其在不同年龄组中分布的研究表明，所有主要精神疾病的患病率，及其在不同年龄组中的分布表明，所有主要精神疾病的患病率，
including depression, anxiety disorders, substance abuse disorders, tend to be significantly lower in older adults than, for example, in middle-aged and younger adults. There is one caveat to that because these data could potentially be affected by what we call a survivor effect. That means that people who indeed had those disorders at a younger age did not live until the later age. And we need to put an asterisk on this finding by acknowledging that this could be a possible confound in those days. that. That makes sense. I was wondering that very thing. Let me ask you another question. There's another stereotype out there of the greedy geyser claiming that old people are a drain on society. Is there any truth to that? I mean, the fact is if you live longer, maybe you've got more financial security than
包括抑郁症、焦虑症、药物滥用障碍，在老年人中往往显著低于中年人和年轻人。对此有一个注意事项，因为这些数据可能会受到我们所谓的“幸存者效应”的影响。这意味着那些在年轻时确实患有这些疾病的人可能没有活到老年。我们需要在这一发现上加一个星号，承认这可能是这些研究中一个可能的混杂因素。这很有道理。我刚才就在想这个问题。让我问您另一个问题。外面还有一种关于“贪婪的老家伙”（greedy geezer）的刻板印象，声称老年人是社会的负担。这有什么道理吗？我的意思是，事实是如果你活得更久，也许你比
younger people, and certainly, you know, you're taking social security. Are the greedy geysers going to wipe out these supports for older people? There is literally no. support for this greedy geyser notion. And let me explain this from several perspectives. First of all, I think this greedy geyser notion is very often misused and abused by politicians to pitch different generations against each other, especially when it comes to the allocation of resources. And we see that, for example, in the debates about social, We see it in the debates about medical care for older adults. I mean, it is clear that as we get older, we need more medical care, and that creates
年轻人有更多的经济保障，而且当然，你知道，你在领取社会保障金。这些“贪婪的老家伙”会耗尽对老年人的这些支持吗？这种“贪婪的老家伙”的说法完全没有依据。让我从几个角度来解释这一点。首先，我认为这种“贪婪的老家伙”的说法经常被政客误用和滥用，用来挑拨不同代际之间的关系，特别是在资源分配方面。我们看到，例如在关于社会保障的辩论中，我们看到它在关于老年人医疗保健的辩论中。我的意思是，很明显，随着我们变老，我们需要更多的医疗护理，这会产生
health care costs. However, this is counterbalanced by the fact that actually older adults overall contribute to society to an extent that most people do not know. know. And maybe the most convincing example to support this statement is that many older adults, for example, are caregiver, either to a spouse, maybe a disabled grandchild, maybe a neighbor, and so on and so forth. And health care economists have estimated if we would use all the hours that older adults put into caregiving and we would put a monetary value on those hours, it amounts to about 450 billion, and that's with a B, not an M, okay, dollars a year.
医疗保健成本。然而，这被一个事实所抵消，即实际上老年人总体上对社会的贡献程度是大多数人所不知道的。也许支持这一陈述最有力的例子是，许多老年人，例如，是照顾者，可能是照顾配偶、残疾的孙辈、邻居等等。医疗保健经济学家估计，如果我们使用老年人投入到护理工作中的所有时间，并为这些时间赋予货币价值，总额约为4500亿美元，注意是“亿”，不是“万”，好吗？
Wow. Moreover, the monetary value that could be associated or could be attached to the number of hours that, you know, middle-aged and older adults put into volunteering in their communities is also quite high. I think estimates have been in the range of $200 to $300 billion. So the contributions that older adults make to the U.S. society and, of course, other societies are really underestimated. And I think that the United States is, and I think that the U.S. society, and of course, they really do not support the notion of the greedy geese. Also, older adults, many older adults,
哇。此外，中年和老年人投入到社区志愿服务中的时间所关联的货币价值也相当高。我认为估计值在2000亿到3000亿美元之间。因此，老年人对美国社会以及其他社会的贡献确实被低估了。我认为美国社会确实不支持“贪婪的老家伙”这种说法。此外，许多老年人，
I don't want to say that poverty in older adults has been completely eradicated. I think there are still subgroups of older adults who are at a disadvantage, but most older adults have reasonable financial security. Now, you and other researchers have found that believing negative aging stereotypes can actually harm people's physical and mental health as they get older. Can you talk about that? Yes, yes. So the colleague that probably has done most of the convincing and supportive work in this area is actually my colleague Becca Levy at Yale University. Now, our research has contributed to this too, and there are a number of other psychologists and colleagues in the gerontology area who have made significant contributions.
我不想说老年人的贫困问题已经完全根除。我认为仍然有部分老年人处于弱势，但大多数老年人拥有合理的经济保障。现在，您和其他研究人员发现，相信负面的衰老刻板印象实际上会损害人们变老后的身心健康。您能谈谈这一点吗？是的，是的。在这个领域做了最令人信服和支持性工作的同事实际上是耶鲁大学的贝卡·利维（Becca Levy）。现在，我们的研究也对此做出了贡献，还有许多其他心理学家和老年学领域的同事也做出了重大贡献。
So I really want to acknowledge the work that these individuals have done and then describe in a more summary way why negative age stereotypes are dangerous, especially if people engage. in negative self-stereotyping. That means applying those negative age stereotypes to their own person. First of all, there is plenty of evidence that when people, when we activate, for example, either in an experiment or through a questionnaire, people's negative age stereotypes,
所以我真的想承认这些人所做的工作，然后以更总结的方式描述为什么负面的年龄刻板印象是危险的，特别是如果人们参与了负面的自我刻板印象。这意味着将那些负面的年龄刻板印象应用到他们自己身上。首先，有大量证据表明，当人们，当我们激活，例如在实验中或通过问卷调查，人们对年龄的负面刻板印象时，
that it affects their behavior. It affects their behavior that they show poor memory performance, they start to walk slower, their handwriting becomes shakier, and so on and so forth. Even people, their will to live, becomes shortcut to some extent, right? Now, those findings come from experimental studies, really well-controlled experimental studies. When we look at quasi-experimental studies, that means, Sometimes we have data that was observational in nature and we can retroactively analyze them. There is evidence that people who have more negative fuse of their own aging, that means who hold more negative age stereotypes, tend to live not as long as people with positive fuse of their own aging.
这会影响他们的行为。这会影响他们的行为，表现为记忆力下降、走路变慢、笔迹变得颤抖等等。甚至人们的生存意志也会在一定程度上缩短，对吧？这些发现来自实验研究，是非常严谨的对照实验研究。当我们观察准实验研究时，这意味着有时我们拥有观察性质的数据，可以进行追溯分析。有证据表明，那些对自己衰老持有更负面看法的人，也就是持有更多负面年龄刻板印象的人，往往比那些对自己衰老持有正面看法的人寿命更短。
They tend to show more shrinkage of hippocampal volume, for example. They tend to be more prone to experiencing heart attacks or cardiovascular events. So the evidence is clearly there, even when it is correlational in nature. Now, why is that? I think all these findings suggest that negative H-strand. stereotypes undermine people's motivation and behavior to engage in those behaviors that actually can optimize healthy aging. So what do we know about how much of our changes as we age as we age is under our own control
例如，他们往往表现出更多的海马体萎缩。他们往往更容易经历心脏病发作或心血管事件。因此，证据显然是存在的，即使它是相关性的。那么，这是为什么呢？我认为所有这些发现都表明，负面的年龄刻板印象削弱了人们参与那些实际上可以优化健康衰老的行为的动力和意愿。那么，关于我们衰老过程中的变化有多少是在我们自己的控制之下，我们了解多少呢？
versus how much is determined by genetics or just like the flip of a coin? I mean, when you look, let's say, at meta-analysis that have been done, that look at what is the genetic contribution to certain behaviors. Usually we see estimates of about 30 to 40 percent that is due to genetics, which if you flip that around, the remainder is then due to environmental factors. that means 60 to 70% is due to environmental factors, and many of those environmental factors are under our control. And I think when I, for example, talk to people out in the community, and I share this information with them, very often there is an aha moment that people really realize that aging is not something,
又有多少是由基因决定的，或者仅仅像掷硬币一样随机？我的意思是，当你查看已经完成的元分析，观察某些行为的遗传贡献时，通常我们看到的估计值约为30%到40%归因于遗传，如果你反过来想，剩下的就是环境因素。这意味着60%到70%归因于环境因素，而其中许多环境因素是在我们控制之下的。当我与社区中的人们交谈并与他们分享这些信息时，他们经常会有一种恍然大悟的感觉，真正意识到衰老并不是某种……
because this is one of those beliefs, oh, aging is just running its course, and because most of it is genetically determined, there is really not a lot I can do. But I think when I describe what we know from scientific literature, right, people actually start to recognize that maybe they are not taking enough opportunity and taking not enough control of their own aging. And we have actually incorporated this into a program, a psychoeducational program, where we systematically provide information
因为这是那些信念之一，哦，衰老只是顺其自然，而且因为大部分是基因决定的，我真的无能为力。但我认为当我描述我们从科学文献中了解到的内容时，人们实际上开始意识到，也许他们没有抓住足够的机会，也没有对自己衰老的过程进行足够的控制。我们实际上已经将其纳入了一个项目，一个心理教育项目，我们系统地提供信息，
to motivate people, really, to engage in behavior change and adopt behaviors such as becoming physically more active to promote healthier aging. Let's talk for business. minute about this idea that ageism is one of the last socially acceptable prejudices in the United States. How prevalent do you think age bias is? And when and how are people most likely to experience it? Do we know? Yeah. Actually, the best data on this, regarding this question, comes from a fairly recent survey that was done in December 2019 at the University of Michigan.
真正激励人们参与行为改变，并采取诸如变得更加积极运动以促进健康衰老等行为。让我们花一分钟谈谈这个观点，即年龄歧视是美国最后一种社会可接受的偏见之一。你认为年龄偏见有多普遍？人们最有可能在何时何地经历它？我们知道吗？是的。实际上，关于这个问题的最好数据来自2019年12月密歇根大学进行的一项相当新的调查。
And it was a national survey where people were asked whether they experienced ageism in their everyday lives. And 82% of the respondents said, yes, indeed, there are incidents of everyday events. ageism that I am exposed to. Now, when the research is, so 82%, can you imagine, that's a big number. That's a big number, right? It's not 10%, it's not 20%. I mean, 82% is really a big number, and it supports this argument that actually ageism is quite prevalent, right? Now, 65% of those answers were that people said, oh, it is in remarks that people make toward me, right? That I clearly am told, look, you're over the hill, you're an unproductive individual or whatever, right? I mean, really, ages kind of remarks, like along the lines of, you know, what do you want, you old geyser, right?
这是一项全国性调查，询问人们是否在日常生活中经历过年龄歧视。82%的受访者表示，是的，确实，我接触过日常年龄歧视事件。现在，当研究结果显示82%时，你能想象吗，这是一个很大的数字。这是一个很大的数字，对吧？不是10%，也不是20%。我的意思是，82%确实是一个很大的数字，它支持了年龄歧视相当普遍的论点，对吧？现在，65%的回答是人们说，哦，这是人们对我发表的言论，对吧？我被明确告知，看，你已经过时了，你是一个没有生产力的人，或者其他什么，对吧？我的意思是，确实是那种年龄歧视的言论，比如，你想干什么，你这个老古董，对吧？
And then they broke it down even further, about, I think, 45% said it occurred in direct interactions, sometimes in the workplace, sometimes in settings like medical care, and so on. But it is a real phenomenon. And my educated guess is it is a real phenomenon because, Of course, people engage in these kinds of behaviors of an ageist nature because they're unaware of it. It happens unwittingly. It's not that people want to be hostile or anything, but they are simply not aware. Like even a remark like, oh, you're actually looking good for your age, right?
然后他们进一步细分，大约45%的人说它发生在直接互动中，有时在工作场所，有时在医疗护理等环境中。但这确实是一个真实的现象。我的专业推测是，这是一个真实的现象，因为人们参与这些年龄歧视性质的行为是因为他们没有意识到。它是无意中发生的。并不是人们想要怀有敌意或什么，他们只是没有意识到。就像即使是像“哦，你看起来比实际年龄年轻”这样的评论，
Yeah. I mean, well, how am I supposed to look when I'm 67? Right. Right. So a lot of this ageist behavior really happens unwittingly, and I think the only way we can really combat it and counteracted is by making people aware, right, that sometimes they unknowingly really engage in age's behavior. On the converse side of that coin, are people's attitudes actually getting more positive toward aging at this point? I mean, first of all, we've got all these baby boomers who are getting older, reaching not just middle age, but old age. And, you know, I'm thinking as more people are working longer, that more younger people are getting exposed to older people. So are we seeing any changes in attitudes, I think is what I'm basically asking?
是的。我的意思是，好吧，我67岁时应该看起来怎么样？对吧。所以很多这种年龄歧视行为确实是无意中发生的，我认为我们真正能够打击和抵制它的唯一方法就是让人们意识到，有时他们会在不知不觉中参与年龄歧视行为。反过来说，人们对衰老的态度现在是否变得更加积极了？我的意思是，首先，我们有这么多婴儿潮一代正在变老，不仅到了中年，而且到了老年。而且，我在想，随着越来越多的人工作更长时间，更多的年轻人接触到老年人。所以我们是否看到了态度的任何变化，我想这基本上就是我想问的？
Well, the answer overall is we are not seeing these changes yet on a broad scale. I think we see it when people actually have the opportunity to interact with older adults. Let's say if someone stays in the workplace later and younger workers have the opportunity, to really see what this person is still capable of, the expertise that the person may have acquired over the years. Then I think through intergenerational contact and really direct experiences, people's views of older adults as a crew can change. And I would see that as positive.
嗯，总的来说，我们还没有在广泛范围内看到这些变化。我认为当人们真正有机会与老年人互动时，我们看到了这种变化。比方说，如果有人在工作场所待得更久，年轻员工有机会真正看到这个人仍然具备的能力，以及这个人多年来积累的专业知识。那么我认为通过代际接触和真正的直接体验，人们对老年人作为一个群体的看法是可以改变的。我会认为这是积极的。
However, this does not happen yet on a broad scale. For example, there have been studies that have been looking at how are older adults perceived in the social media. And again, Becca Levy and her students and colleagues have published on this. And what they have coined this is the age stereotype paradox. On one hand, we know that aging can occur in a more positive ways, but why do attitudes toward older adults do not keep people? not keep pace with this? Why are most of the fuse of older adults still more negative than is actually justified? And that's what they described as the age stereotype paradox.
然而，这还没有在广泛范围内发生。例如，有一些研究观察了老年人在社交媒体上是如何被感知的。同样，贝卡·利维（Becca Levy）和她的学生及同事也发表过相关文章。他们将其称为“年龄刻板印象悖论”。一方面，我们知道衰老可以以更积极的方式发生，但为什么对老年人的态度却没有跟上呢？为什么大多数对老年人的看法仍然比实际情况更负面？这就是他们所描述的年龄刻板印象悖论。
What do you think of these programs that aim to counteract this bias by bringing together older and younger adults to get to know each other? For example, I've read a programs that bring seniors to live and study on college campuses. Are these programs effective, do you think? I am very much in favor of these intergenerational programs where younger generations can see what older generations are capable of because, and then, of course, older adults can learn and break down stereotypes about younger people. So I think, I think, the, these programs are really great. They hopefully help us to get rid of these stereotypes of the greedy geyser,
你如何看待那些旨在通过让老年人和年轻人聚在一起相互了解来抵制这种偏见的计划？例如，我读过一些让老年人到大学校园生活和学习的计划。你认为这些计划有效吗？我非常支持这些代际计划，因为年轻一代可以看到老一代的能力，而且，当然，老年人也可以学习并打破对年轻人的刻板印象。所以我认为，这些计划真的很棒。希望它们能帮助我们摆脱那些关于贪婪老人的刻板印象，
but also of, let's say, the rebellious and ignorant young adult, right, that actually, for example, older adults can see, well, young adults, like college students or high school students, they are concerned about the environment and what the older adults will leave. behind for them right and maybe we can form a coalition maybe we can work together in a in a more harmonious way to award the same goals right because older adults want to leave behind a legacy hopefully of a world that is better than when they when they grew up and younger adults look forward to
还有，比如说，叛逆和无知的年轻人，对吧？实际上，例如，老年人可以看到，嗯，年轻人，比如大学生或高中生，他们关心环境以及老年人会给他们留下什么，对吧？也许我们可以结成联盟，也许我们可以以一种更和谐的方式共同努力，以实现相同的目标，对吧？因为老年人希望留下一个遗产，希望是一个比他们成长时更好的世界，而年轻人期待着
having a world that is worth living in so I I'm very much in favor of those programs Now, in terms of whether they are effective, I don't have a complete overview, and I really want to be completely open about that. But those studies that I have looked at actually have shown quite some positive results that are encouraging and promising. And so I would think that these programs indeed help to break down intergenerational barriers, intergenerational tensions. and also help to break down age stereotypes on both sides, really. On a more macro level, what could we be doing as a society to counteract age bias that maybe we're not doing right now? I think, for example, the media could play a very important role.
拥有一个值得生活的世界，所以我非常支持这些计划。现在，至于它们是否有效，我没有一个完整的概述，我真的想对此完全坦诚。但我所看过的那些研究确实显示了一些积极的结果，这些结果是令人鼓舞和有希望的。所以我认为这些计划确实有助于打破代际障碍、代际紧张关系，也确实有助于打破双方的年龄刻板印象。在更宏观的层面上，作为一个社会，我们能做些什么来抵制我们现在可能没有做的年龄偏见？我认为，例如，媒体可以发挥非常重要的作用。
Currently, we know, again, from numerous studies that older adults are not, very positively portrayed in the media. That means TV shows, movies, and so on. I think the media could play a more positive role in really showing how older adults really are. And that means not going either extreme. That means not only showing the frail and adults who are inflicted by illness and also not showing the superstars, but really show what aging looks like for quote unquote the average person, which indeed that has improved tremendously because people tend to have higher levels of education. People tend to have better on average again, better access to health care.
目前，我们再次从无数研究中得知，老年人在媒体中的形象并不非常正面。这意味着电视节目、电影等等。我认为媒体可以在真正展示老年人的真实面貌方面发挥更积极的作用。这意味着不要走极端。这意味着不仅要展示那些体弱多病的老年人，也不要只展示超级明星，而是真正展示所谓的“普通人”的衰老是什么样子的，这确实有了巨大的改善，因为人们往往有更高的教育水平。人们往往平均而言有更好的医疗保健机会。
And when I say on average, of course, I want to acknowledge that there are certain groups in our society were disadvantaged has accumulated over time and that minorities are disproportionately affected by those problems. But I think on average, aging has become more positive. And that's why in one of my publications I opened the publication with a statement, is the 60, the new 40, for example, right? because it sort of implies that at a later age now, most people actually feel younger and may do things that people at a younger age usually would do.
当我平均而言时，我当然想承认，我们社会中某些群体的劣势是随着时间的推移而积累的，少数群体不成比例地受到这些问题的影响。但我认为平均而言，衰老已经变得更加积极。这就是为什么在我的出版物之一中，我以这样一句话开头：60岁是新的40岁，对吧？因为它暗示了在以后的年龄，大多数人实际上感觉更年轻，并且可能会做一些年轻人通常会做的事情。
So last question. I often like to wrap up with this. What are you studying now? What are the big questions in the field that still remain to be answered? Well, we just finished a clinical trial. And it was the clinical trial where we take. the efficacy of this intervention program. Because I think, you know, it is not only critically important
所以最后一个问题。我经常喜欢用这个来结束。你现在在研究什么？领域中还有哪些重大问题有待回答？嗯，我们刚刚完成了一项临床试验。这是一项临床试验，我们测试了这个干预项目的有效性。因为我认为，你知道，这不仅至关重要，
to show that we can change people's attitudes toward their own aging, but we also have to show that this then has downstream effects that people indeed change their behavior, right? And I think that is still a big challenge, and I definitely, will continue to study this more and hopefully help to identify avenues that allow us to do. Because, you know, the ultimate outcome that we should be interested in as psychologists
不仅要证明我们可以改变人们对自己衰老的态度，我们还必须证明这会产生后续影响，即人们确实改变了他们的行为，对吧？我认为这仍然是一个巨大的挑战，我肯定会继续深入研究这一点，并希望有助于确定让我们能够做到这一点的途径。因为，你知道，作为心理学家，我们应该感兴趣的最终结果
is to improve individuals' quality of life, but also help to improve how society addresses the aging population and the phenomenon that more people in our society are individuals of an older age. Well, Dr. Deal, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to us. Thank you. Well, thank you so much for having me and for giving me this opportunity to share my work with your audience. It's great information. Thanks again. read more about Dr. Deals and other psychologists work to combat ageism and reframe aging in the March issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Visit our website at www.combeingof Psychology.org and go to this episode's related links. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology
是改善个人的生活质量，同时也帮助改善社会应对老龄化人口的方式，以及我们社会中更多人是高龄个体的现象。好吧，迪尔博士，这真的很有趣。我很感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢。好吧，非常感谢你邀请我，并给我这个机会与你的听众分享我的工作。这是很棒的信息。再次感谢。在APA杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）三月刊中阅读更多关于迪尔博士和其他心理学家打击年龄歧视和重塑衰老的工作。访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 并转到本集的相关链接。你可以在我们的网站上或在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学访谈》的往期节目。
on our website or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And again, we'd like to hear from you about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like to hear from us, so please go to our website and look for a link to the listener's survey. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次，我们想听听你对这个播客的看法以及你想从我们这里听到什么，所以请访问我们的网站并寻找听众调查的链接。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。